he actually tweeted a really nice
uh tweet thread
uh it says quote a year ago a friend
recommended i do daily affirmations
and i was skeptical
but i was going through major
transitions in my life so i gave it a
shot and it set me on a journey of
self-acceptance and self-love
so
what was that like you may maybe
talk through this idea of affirmations
and how that helped you yeah
because really like i'm just like me i'm
a kind i like to think of myself as a
kind person in general but i'm kind of
mean to myself sometimes yeah
and so um i've been doing journaling for
almost 10 years now um
i use an app called day one and it's
awesome i just journal and i use it as
an opportunity to almost have a
conversation with the debbie downer
voice in my it's like a rebuttal right
like debbie downer says oh my god like
you you know you won't be able to raise
this round of funny i'm like okay let's
talk about it
i have a track record of doing x y and z
i think i can do this and it's it's
literally like
so i wouldn't i don't know that i can
shut off the voice but i can have a
conversation with it and it just it just
um
and i bring data to the table right
[Laughter]
nice so so that was the journaling part
which i found very helpful
but the affirmation took it to a whole
next level and i i just love it i i'm
i'm a year into doing this and you
literally wake up in the morning and the
first thing you do
um i meditate first um and then and then
i write my affirmations and it's it's
the energy i want to put out in the
world that hopefully will come right
back to me so
i will say i always start with my smile
lights up the whole world
and i kid you not like people in the
street will stop me and say oh my god
like we love your smile yeah like yes
[Laughter]
so so my affirmations will change
depending on
you know what's happening this day is it
funny i know don't judge don't judge no
that's not why laughter is not judgment
it's just awesome i mean it uh it's true
but you're saying affirmations somehow
help
kind of uh i mean what is it that they
do work
to like remind you of the kind of person
you are and the kind of person you want
to be
which
actually may be in reverse order the
kind of person you want to be and that
helps you become the kind of person you
actually are
it just it brings intentionality to like
what you're doing right and so by the
way i was laughing because my
affirmations which i also do are the
opposite oh you do oh
i don't have a
my smile lights up
what maybe i should add that because
like i i have i just i have everything
oh my boy
i just
it's uh it's much more stoic like
about
focused about this i was kind of okay
but the joy the emotion that you're just
in that little affirmation is beautiful
so maybe i should add
that i have some i have some like focus
stuff yeah but that's usually that's a
cool start that's good it's just that
after all the like smiling you're
inspired playful and joyful and all that
and then it's like okay i kick butt
let's get [ __ ] done right this is the
get [ __ ] done affirmation okay cool so
like what else is on there
oh what else is on there um well
i i have i'm also i'm i'm a magnet for
all sorts of things so i'm an amazing
people magnet i attract like awesome
people into my universe
uh that's an actual affirmation yes
that's great yeah so that that's and
that yeah and that somehow manifests
itself into like
working i think so
yeah like can you speak to like why it
feels good to do the affirmations
i honestly think it just
grounds the day
and then it allows me to instead of just
like being pulled
back and forth like throughout the day
it just like grounds me i'm like okay
like
this thing happened it's not exactly
what i wanted it to be but i'm patient
or i'm
you know i'm
i trust that the universe will do
amazing things for me which is one of my
other consistent affirmations or i'm an
amazing mom right and so i can grapple
with all the feelings of mom guilt that
i have all the time
um or here's another one i'm a love
magnet and i literally say i will kind
of picture the person that i'd love to
end up with and i write it all down and
it hasn't happened yet but what are you
what are you picturing this is brad pitt
because that's what i picture okay
that's what you picture yeah
running holding hands running together
um no more like fight club of that uh
the fight club brad pitt where he's like
staying all right people will know okay
anyway i'm sorry i'll get off on that do
you have uh like when you're thinking
about the being a love magnet in that
way
are you picturing specific people or is
this almost like um
in the space of like energy
right it's somebody who
um
is smart and well accomplished and
successful in their life but they're
generous and they're well traveled and
they want to travel the world
things like that like their head over
heels into me is like i know it sounds
super silly but it's literally what i
write yeah and i believe it'll happen
one day you actually write so you don't
say it out loud no i write it i write
all my affirmations
i do the absolutely i say uh
yeah if i'm alone i'll say it out loud
yeah
i should try that
i think it's which
what feels more powerful to you to me
more powerful
saying stuff feels more powerful yeah
writing
is um
writing feels like i'm
losing
losing the words
like losing the power of the words maybe
because that writes though do you hand
write
no i i type it's on this app it's day
one basically and i just i can look the
best thing about it is i can look back
yeah and see like a year ago what was i
affirming right
so it's also changes over time it it it
hasn't like changed a lot but it but the
focus kind of changes over time i got it
yeah i say the same exact thing over and
over and over oh you do okay there's a
comfort in the in the sameness of it
you